candace you have me pissed off from my
head down to my shoes because this damn
song is stuck in the head every single
day on my life
over you brains
got me pissed off from my head down to
my shoes
boy
how are you receiving all the love
because it's it's an r b hit regardless
of potomac or not thank you for saying
that that that means so much to me
because that's literally
what i wanted it to be i wanted the song
to feel like something that could
transcend
just this space i'm like not processing
all of the love it's too much
and i'm excited to show you guys more
we're we're going to be sprinkling
the road with with another single very
soon and then the album is coming out
soon after that and we're going to see
some of this journey play out on season
six including i would imagine the
filming behind the scenes of the drive
back video which features your co-stars
yes
we we had we had an audition process
okay everybody didn't just get in okay
yes they had to audition
[Music]
it was amazing and having the girls be
on set for that final scene
um that you see in drive back was so
much fun they were really great sports
they came dressed honey they
they followed the protocols so it was
great to have one there you said there
was an audition process though so did
anybody almost not make the cut
i hope they show this because yes so
some of the saints
i had to extend a little bit of grace to
some of the saints because
yeah it was so funny it's so so so fun
uh someone who's not in the video is
your husband though chris was in the
back doing what husbanders do supporting
me making sure everything was in line
and and cussing and fussing and i think
you'll see some of that in next week's
episode too okay
helping you live out the dream by
picking up some of the maybe
less dreamlike parts of this uh
experience has mama dorothy come around
the idea of chris
and you
taking your marriage and turning it into
a business partnership have i told you
that
chris is like managing me i call him my
husband juror
okay
i think that
she will probably always
side eye it because my mom
wants to be
the kris jenner in my life okay so
there's a little jealousy at play she
wants that control that you're giving
over to chris okay yes yes this very
moment
with everything the party parts first
and what did you make of nicki minaj
throwing a little slight shade on the
song on instagram
okay so
the the nicki minaj
saga because it's like ever growing and
changing right like it's just too much
stress for me i did not take what she
said about my song as shade i took
because the what happened was watch what
happens live
posted under her post about
hosting the reunion um that she should
do a um a feature
remix yeah a remix of drive back and she
was like what's that like she didn't
know what they were talking about but
then after they explained oh we're
talking about candace's song she said oh
it's a nice song but then she's like
okay we have things to talk about at the
reunion and now we're okay girl bye like
get on this track and then let's go home
i ain't talking to you about nothing to
happen in season five good night but i
love the idea of her coming in for a
segment and you know doing
whatever like whatever i would be so
open to that and then she can go with me
to the studio and get on this track
the real that's the goal that's the goal
you might have to answer some of those
tough questions to convince her to do
that but hey maybe give her one yeah
i'll give her one even trade
one question for eight bars
i love it well season six is going at
like a hundred miles an hour how are you
feeling about this season is it what you
wanted it to be coming off of
the mess that was last year
this season i think is
what i thought
my first season would be like and what i
thought when i pictured myself in this
experience
this is what i saw
and that's what you know i wish the
audience had gotten to see from the
beginning you were just seeing that one
part of me and i i'm i'm happy that the
audience and that you guys are getting
to see
another part of me this season has been
fun for me so far this is the first time
i'm hosting the girls so we are going to
have fun thank you thank you or you have
a good time or get out williamsburg
seems to be where a lot of what we saw
in the season trailer goes down oh yeah
on a scale from
one to wig shift
how intense is the the trip to
williamsburg it's pretty intense um it's
it's probably uh
almost a full tilt wig shift moment okay
um
only because it comes out of nowhere i'm
putting your ass on notice don't with my
family
[Music]
these [ __ ] cameras wendy what
try lightning
that moment was intense and it kind of
lingered obviously for the rest of the
trip but then we kind of got back
together and and
and worked it out
wendy maybe not so much but we tried
yeah i want to get to that but let's
rewind to where we left things off
karen versus giselle part who knows what
carol this is old bring something new
you're bringing up the old
i'm not going to think oh you're
bringing up something that happened one
two three four years ago
is there any hope that these two can get
to a place where i don't know a
friendship's possible but like where
barbs aren't just like tossed back and
forth
you know it's
every day is a challenge with those two
there are some more ebbs and flows and
there are some breakthrough moments with
them that i was shocked by but then it
kind of goes left again
so the answer is i have no idea i'm just
going to have my hard hat on
at all times with those two and move
through the mess yourself again you have
your own
issues with
the grand dom with mrs hunger i do why
would i assassinate you that way if i
cared about you why i don't believe this
can we clear up some speculation some
rumors about this
people think you skipped wendy's nude
interlude one to avoid seeing karen yes
true or false
uh categorically false okay i ain't
scared of no
bleep
okay
i run from no one
i don't fuss with anybody but the devil
unless i have to okay i was having some
issues
with my lower hemisphere
and i had to sit down
that's all and i i hate because that was
the first outcast event i was devastated
that i had to miss it but i i i could
not have gone in driving wendy lives in
west bumble america
i just i was too nervous to have to ride
in the car for two hours
with my stomach being in without access
to proper plumbing let's say exactly
that clears up the second thought people
had which is that you were holding out
about even returning to the show and
maybe some creative puzzle piecing was
going on to to make it appear that way
but you were ill that day you would have
been there if not for that 100
karen teased to me you've teased that
there's some progress on that front but
it's never going to be what it was
it just it is what it is it's not worth
arguing over because i'm not in the
business of trying to change entire
human beings
i can only change myself karen is for
karen i can't change that
well people have picked up on she has
what's turning out to be a pattern of
taking the new girl under her wing and
then what happens you know
a year or two in do you predict that
same fate for mia uh the short answer is
yeah i do it very much gives
let me attach myself to
someone
who
is looking for guidance
and you know ride that out until
they see who i am and then dip dip out
peace out okay
moving on from karen
and giselle is the gisele and wendy
which you teased a minute ago
gisele has maintained that she brought
up these eddie rumors
as a friend as someone who is concerned
that the this information might be out
there about a woman in her social circle
wendy's interpretation is no this is a
malicious attack on my family do you
think one side is right one side is
wrong is the truth somewhere in between
how do you process that situation
i still haven't processed it
[Music]
mostly because i've never believed the
rumors i think that one thing that wendy
did say and i i echoed was that i just
hated that
we were giving once again a platform on
our platform to
these horrific people who literally eat
off of our pain
that's where i was with it i just i wish
that there was there was just something
else to talk about but it was a sneak
attack for wendy because i think wendy
thought she was safe with gisele right
and what what we all must learn dear
grasshopper is that no one is safe with
gisele okay and the sooner you learn
that the quicker that you can kind of
let things roll off your back she was
just like shocked and hurt in every
emotion was just right on her face
because she she thought that she was
immune to gisele's
tirades and her her terrorism right and
i well i think also watching the show
back seems to be a little eye opening
too and she pointed out on social media
that you know giselle this was really
you wanted to come and comfort your
girlfriend in a time of need why would
you bring this up not once but twice
yeah um so
there's some these are great questions
for the reunion things
um how does their
blow up
then change the course of the season
does it
can they be in the same room after that
well
yes and no um it was a little awkward
but no more so than when thelma and
louise gizelle and karen are going back
and forth
um
wendy is you know very mature very smart
woman so she knows how to you know pick
herself up and carry on we are better
able this season to move forward
there isn't a lot of lingering whereas
like last season we were stuck on like
one or two things
for eight 19 episodes
we
we are able to pick up and move quicker
this season which i appreciate and what
do you make about everyone being so up
in arms about wendy's sexier fashion
choices this season
girl the girl is showing off her new
titties honey
let happy and nest have their let harry
and ness breathe
i've seen more of your body parts yeah
in the past month than i have the entire
time i've known you
the wendy i met last year was not that
loose they're just trying to get settled
into their cavities okay
and new booty wendy is here to stay
i love it i think it's amazing so
everybody gets work done so i don't
understand why it's a thing that wendy
is celebrating her new body people just
like to point out the obvious sometimes
everything
um what else to do in williamsburg we're
also going to see you come face to face
with ashley after not inviting her to
not one but now two
group events
what is at the core of your beef with
her would you say i've lost it a little
bit in the years of the back and forth
i'm like what is the issue what is the
actual issue here so you know what it's
funny i don't think anyone has ever
publicly asked me that question so i'm
gonna give you the answer and i don't
think anyone has ever
gotten this answer publicly
so and i've had to think about it too
because i i kind of got lost in it as
well so for me
when i first joined this cast when i
first joined this group of girls
i came in as ashley's friend we love
each other through the pageant world
and
as
a friend i have a standard of protocols
loyalty is one of them
if
for example when wendy came in i
welcomed her with open arms i introduced
her to the group i stood by her i called
her every other day i made sure she was
good i checked in with her
i was i was her friend
i didn't get that from ashley ashley
kind of brought me in she dumped me on
the side of the road and then she was
shading me in confessionals
you know five minutes after i joined the
cast candace she was in some off-brand
pageant she won miss united states
miss united states
i didn't even see that until it aired
and i was like wow like who is this girl
and from there it kind of just
became
just a bunch of fussing matches
but the the true catalyst for me was
when she involved herself in legal
matters
simply to be vindictive and that's what
she said she said i you know now we're
even is what she said to me her she's
worried about herself the
liar
who could not handle
my mouth
and decided it was in her best interest
to put her hands on me and then lie
about it
you
you ashley
perry that is completely fine and i
respect your opponent right doing so
good
you don't care watch me not care better
than you okay that the context of the
season one your first season experience
helps to color all of that because it
was the aftermath of watching the show
that set the ball in motion got it
she has none
andy you know what that's my issue with
candace on watch evans live she said her
issue with you is that you're constantly
changing where the line is no matter how
much you try to talk to her about
something and confront her about
something she's always gonna find some
way to you know like push it off shove
it off what's your reaction to her
explaining what she feels her issue is
with you i think it's poppycock because
ashley is the queen of deflection
um the queen of deflection she's full of
you know what and like i i literally pay
her no mind
none because she she's you can't take
anything she says seriously she's
disloyal to everybody and people like
that are dangerous people so i stay
far far away
we will move on to the salad toss
does the salad toss happen in
williamsburg too or is that a future
something no everybody is like oh my god
candace is being so nice to me and then
she throws salad in her face
yes that is true but no that the talent
toss happens on our second trip which i
was not hosting
yes
can you give me any hints as to why
that
happens
yes i can
so because it was a slow burn so you see
so far i'm
team like i like her she's fun
um she's she's very candid
and she's she's great for me as someone
who's watching it all now i enjoy
watching her um and i know that the
audience does too you kind of see her
one by one just kind of picking off
each of us she takes a moment to haze
everybody in the group except for karen
um and at this time i have not had my
turn so when it's my turn and you'll see
that play out in future episodes
i was i was here for her until i was and
and i think
true to form with with those who can't
handle it in this group
when when my mouth gets going sometimes
you lose your words
and you just gotta pick up salad i guess
undressed salad you know to that
it was not wet yeah
okay so safe to say your opinion of mia
changed over the course of shooting this
season
it did it did and then it changed again
when i started watching okay which i
will address at the reunion but it's
just
lots of shifts with with with that mia
always with this group a lot of shifts
uh in the trailer there's a moment i
think it's connected to the salitas or
same day or something where it's like
production is having to escort you
like protect you once again
yeah yeah that was i think that was the
salad sauce that was that day um
i don't think it was
i think it was chris
oh but
and it's it's a bunch of people just
separating um me and mia from one
another we were never close it was never
like gonna be right it was like
pre-emptive oh yeah it's just something
okay let's separate and you see wendy's
long arms doing what he said when do you
find yourself in the middle every time
like
she's screaming
like girl what are you doing yeah it was
it's i can laugh at it now
but in the moment i was like
yeah in the moment i'm sure you were
like not again
yeah this is a mess yeah y'all need to
just pick up a dictionary learn to learn
to put your words together girl there
you go
um there is a lot of season left to
watch is there anything that you're
super excited for the viewers to
experience or for you to get to watch
back
obviously to watch out to play out the
rest of the the music journey from the
season the end um
speaking to my label and and figuring
things out with the label i'm excited to
see that play out and just and see my
team like my team that you know has
helped me to get to this point to kind
of document this with them has been
really cool and really amazing and how
cool to have a dream realized and
captured for eternity uh with reality tv
cameras is there on the flip side is
there anything that you are dreading
having to watch back or that the
audience should be bracing for
i got pretty
intense and emotional about
my baby journey it's a lot of raw
moments and it's very vulnerable and i
just
you know i'm at this point i know
everybody hates when i cry and i'm i'm
not looking forward to people being like
oh she's crying again i was gonna say
i'm sure part of the
the trepidation is all the commentary
and conversation that will come on
social media which i've noticed you've
been not shy about putting out people's
main messages and said how do you like
this which i applaud you for
it's i usually don't um because i get a
lot of crazy messages but sometimes it
just it goes so far
and people need to understand how
toxic social media can be
and and do better you know and i say
this as someone who has had my moments
where i've said mean things to people on
social media like that stuff is just
it's it's dangerous and we we have to do
better at the end of the day people you
guys are brave to share your lives for
our entertainment right and that's what
it's about it's entertainment even there
you know for that one hour for those 45
minutes or whatever it is
take it for entertainment you know if
there's a lesson to be learned in it you
don't know me girl i'm
it's very it's very much giving stan
it's giving eminem's stand and nobody
has time well and there's like there's
always a be nice to people or a bible
verse in the bios and i'm like what is
up what oh my god it's
always the one that's
i'm i i'm just tired of god but if you
you ugly yeah but let me judge everybody
yes
it's that you are so right bryce it's
that's hilarious it's always the ones
that are you know the the jesus stompers
but they didn't really come from jesus
okay i would know
you